[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 españa vuelve a ser noticia y a
ocupar las páginas de internacional de
los diarios de todo el mundo esta vez
por las manifestaciones de jóvenes
contra el encarcelamiento del rapero
pablo hasél para hablarnos de este tema
y de otros que ocupan la agenda española
en europa y en latinoamérica hoy hace
escala en parís el embajador de españa
en francia josé manuel álvarez
muchísimas gracias a vosotros por
invitarme bueno las protestas y los
disturbios en barcelona y en otras
ciudades han dado la vuelta al mundo los
jóvenes se manifiestan por pablo hasél
que no es el mejor rapero del mundo pero
tal vez ahora sea el rapero español más
conocido ha ido a la cárcel por nueve
meses por enaltecimiento del terrorismo
injurias a la corona y muchos se
preguntan hay libertad de expresión en
españa por supuesto que la libertad de
expresión yo creo que eso no lo pone
nadie en duda de hecho hay que
diferenciar lo que es enaltecimiento del
terrorismo de lo que es la verdadera
libertad
de la misma forma que hay que
diferenciar lo que es vandalismo y
saqueo de tiendas del derecho a
manifestarse pacífica y libremente hay
libertad de expresión en españa y por
supuesto hay un derecho a manifestarse
pacíficamente lo que hemos visto estos
días que por cierto prácticamente ya ha
remitido de manera total ayer por la
noche había algunas cientos de personas
en barcelona
reposa sobre una minoría de personas en
españa muy jóvenes algunos de ellos
incluso menores de edad bueno pues que
se han dedicado más al vandalismo y al
saqueo que a una libertad de
manifestación eso no quiere decir que
españa como todos los países del mundo
bueno haga un análisis de lo que es su
código penal el gobierno así lo ha
expresado y si hay el consenso
suficiente en el parlamento pues se
mejorará en aquellos aspectos en los que
colisione lo que es la verdadera
libertad de expresión con lo que es el
código penal que justamente se ha
presentado una proposición de ley para
proteger la libertad de expresión que
incluye derogar esos delitos por
injurias a la corona o por
enaltecimiento del terrorismo se tiene
que cambiar el código penal bueno no soy
yo como embajador el que el que debe de
valorar eso lo que si el gobierno el
propio presidente el gobierno varios de
sus miembros lo han expresado si hay
suficiente consenso en el parlamento a
través del ministerio de justicia se
analizarán aquellos aspectos en los que
la libertad de expresión bueno pues no
esté suficientemente matizada o
corregida en aquello que toca al
penal pero insisto una cosa es la
libertad de expresión y otra cosa es
enaltecimiento del terrorismo y desde
luego la violencia es incompatible con
la democracia a toda esta vida
elecciones en cataluña recientemente en
cabeza llegó el socialista salvador y ya
ex ministro de sanidad de pedro sánchez
pero los partidos independentistas suman
más todo parece indicar que los
independentistas podrían formar gobierno
y el problema seguiría siendo el mismo
reclaman un referendo de independencia
la posición del gobierno español ha
variado sobre la convocatoria de un
referéndum y hay margen de negociación
ahora hay varios aspectos no hay que
negar que quien ha ganado las elecciones
es el partido socialista de cataluña con
un candidato salvador y allá que no es
cualquier candidato era el ministro de
sanidad con lo que eso supone también de
ratificación de la política que se está
llevando por parte del gobierno con
respecto al comida y la vacunación
ha triunfado también yo diría la
moderación a los partidos que han
apostado por la moderación el diálogo
acercar posturas avanzar que el gobierno
de cataluña el próximo gobierno de
cataluña se dedique a lo que de verdad
importa que es vacunar y relanzar la
economía y hay varias lecturas
hay una en la que usted ha hecho pero
hay otra las fuerzas progresistas las
fuerzas de izquierdas tienen otra
posibilidad de otro gobierno y no la
posición del gobierno de españa no varía
acaba de cumplir un año como embajador y
ha sido elegido personalidad española
del año por la cámara oficial de
comercio de españa en francia es
diplomático de carrera ha sido el
secretario general de asuntos
internacionales unión europea g20 y
seguridad global en el gobierno español
y es muy cercano al presidente pedro
sánchez ha sido sus sherpas un
negociador en muchas cumbres en muchos
de asuntos como se llevan el presidente
español pedro sánchez y el francés
emmanuel marco extraordinariamente como
sólo puede ser de dos líder
es a los que unen muchas cosas por
supuesto en una etapa generacional
tienen edades similares son dos líderes
jóvenes son de los líderes audaces y
sobre todo son dos líderes claramente
europeístas consideran que muchas de las
soluciones a las dificultades y a los
desafíos a los que se enfrenta españa y
francia es europa y una respuesta
europea como es claramente la situación
del comino
justamente el 15 de febrero se celebra
en francia la cumbre franco-española o
no se sabe muy bien en qué formato el 15
de marzo perdón en y no se sabe muy bien
si será presencial semi-presencial a
causa de la pandemia encima de la mesa
hay varios temas y uno es el plan de la
unión europea para relanzar la economía
maltrecha por la crisis de el
coronavirus
está ese plan que fue muy duro de
alcanzar porque hubo países que no
querían mutualizar la deuda como países
bajos cuando llega el dinero y en que lo
va a gastar españa bueno
ese plan en el que fue decisiva la
participación del presidente pedro
sánchez también de manuel macrón y de
otros presidentes también para españa va
a representar 140 mil millones de euros
a desembolsar en seis años
[Música]
es un plan que va a servir para hacer
aquellas transiciones y aquellas
reformas que ya estaban previstas en
españa pero que con 1.019 ha puesto
sobre la mesa por un lado la necesidad
urgente y por otro lado la posibilidad
también de acelerar las la transición
ecológica toda una transformación de
nuestro modelo económico hacia una
economía verde la transición digital que
nos va a meter en una economía
plenamente del siglo 21 y al mismo
tiempo una mayor cohesión territorial y
social es una gran oportunidad para
aquellas personas que estas transiciones
tanto verde como digital podía dejarlas
fuera del mercado de trabajo podía
dejarlas con digamos unas herramientas
humanas que no les permitiera participar
plenamente de esta nueva dimensión
económica y que permitirá retomar las
esta fue una negociación muy muy dura a
lo largo de su carrera de negociación y
que negociador ha sido han sido los más
complicados
en negociador no recuerdo ninguno yo
siempre sobre todo en mi etapa de ser
para me ha acercado a toda negociación
sabiendo que tal vez el otro no tenía
razón pero que tenía sus razones y
entendiendo las uno consigue acercar
posiciones como negociación difícil
evidentemente yo recuerdo la negociación
del break city en concreto todo lo que
tocaba a la defensa de los intereses de
españa en relación a gibraltar como un
momento especialmente complicado pero yo
creo que hemos conseguido los objetivos
que españa se marcó en aquel momento es
justamente con el tema abres y también
con la pandemia de el coronavirus se ha
puesto de manifiesto lo frágil que puede
resultar la circulación de personas no
en el espacio schengen en la unión
europea
hemos visto por ejemplo que se han
restablecido controles de identidad en
los aeropuertos franceses el mismo
manuel mccomb quiere reformar
el espacio schengen no solo ahora por el
tema de la pandemia sino para la lucha
contra por ejemplo la inmigración ilegal
o el yihadismo
está en peligro la libre circulación de
europeos en el espacio schengen y cuál
es la posición española la posición de
españa es clara y es una defensa de la
integridad del mercado único y de la
integridad del espacio schengen yo creo
que los europeos no debemos de olvidar
lo que debemos a la libre circulación
libre circulación de personas libre
circulación de trabajadores libre
circulación de mercancías el hecho de
tenerlo tan a mano desde hace tantos
años nos puede olvidar hacer olvidar
aquellos tiempos en los que las
fronteras eran auténticas barreras no
tendríamos el nivel de prosperidad ni el
nivel de felicidad personal si
existieran esas barreras por lo tanto
nuestra posición es la defensa de esa
integridad tanto del espacio schengen y
de la libertad de circulación de
personas como del mercado único y con
respecto a la inmigración irregular yo
creo que el gobierno español está entre
aquellos que año a año hacen más por la
lucha contra la inmigración irregular y
contra los los traficantes de seres
humanos es decir el esfuerzo que está
haciendo las fuerzas de seguridad
españolas en lo que es la frontera
exterior de schengen que es una frontera
también de españa' es encomiable año a
año y las cifras demuestran como la
policía española y el gobierno español
están siendo eficaz en esa política
contra la inmigración irregular más allá
de salado
están a favor de reformar schengen
españa estaría a favor de reformar
schengen o no nosotros queremos que
schengen la integridad de schengen y de
la libre circulación de personas debe
mantenerse sin duda alguna por supuesto
cualquier reflexión o cualquier debate
en el que se quiera entrar para mejorar
esa integridad y esa libre circulación
de personas dentro del espacio schengen
siempre se puede mirar pero la posición
de por qué no español es clara buena hay
un acuerdo que no sabemos si algún día
se va a materializar que es el acuerdo
de libre comercio entre los países del
mercosur y la unión europea yo hace 20
años que ejerzo como como periodista y
siempre parece que se va avanzando que
ya estamos con el acuerdo que lo
conseguimos y que ya lo vamos a poner en
marcha pero nunca se acaba de poner en
marcha francia es el último país que ha
puesto trabas
francia acusa al presidente brasileño
jair bolsonaro de no cuidar el amazonas
no quieren garantías no para que se
pueda hacer ese acuerdo de libre
comercio pero la realidad es que los
autores franceses tienen bastantes peros
porque no quieren que se inunde el
mercado de carne sudamericana
porque creen que van a ser perjudicados
qué condiciones pone españa
y puede influir españa en la posición
francesa bueno españa es siempre un gran
defensor de américa latina en el mundo
pero muy claramente en en europa nuestro
idioma común nuestra historia nos hace
sentirnos muy cerca de esos países
hermanos
españa fue decisiva para la firma del
acuerdo de mercosur que hacía 20 años
que se negociaba por lo tanto yo lo
invito a la esperanza se tardaron veinte
años para afirmar lo seguro que se
ratificará y esperemos que no tarden 20
años el propio presidente sánchez
encabezó la firma de una carta en la que
españa no estaba sola estaba también
alemania estaba a suecia estaba la
república checa- había varios países de
la unión europea mercosur es una gran
oportunidad para ambas regiones era el
acuerdo de libre comercio más importante
que exista en el mundo una vez que se
ratifique supondrá una bajada de cuatro
mil millones de euros de aranceles y se
calcula que por cada mil millones de
euros que se incrementa el comercio se
crearán catorce mil puestos de trabajo
por lo tanto es una fantástica
oportunidad para ambas regiones para la
unión europea y para américa latina y es
también una oportunidad si es necesario
debe ser exigente en muchos estándares
españa no se opone a eso pero eso no
puede ser una excusa para la no
ratificación de algo que es mutuamente
beneficioso y españa estará al lado de
la ratificación del acuerdo
y al lado de américa latina siempre cree
que está cerca esa ratificación
no depende ya de mí por supuesto pero ni
siquiera del gobierno de españa'
exclusivamente se necesita una
ratificación ya a nivel del parlamento
europeo pero yo confío en que sí en que
esa ratificación esté lo más cerca
posible de selwo españa trabajará para
ello pues muchísimas gracias señor
embajador josé manuel álvarez por haber
estado con nosotros gracias a vosotros y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]